كان قرار النظام السوري سحب الخدمات التي
تقدمها الدوله مثل الاطفاء والاسعاف
والرعايه الصحيه وصيانه شبكات المياه
والكهرباء عن المدن والاحياء الخارجه عن
سيطرته بالتزامن مع القصف العنيف لها
المحفز الاول لظهور مبادرات تطوعيه في تلك
المناطق لمحاوله ملء الفراغ والاستجابه
لنداءات الاستغاثه هناك وتقديم المساعدات
لمن يطلبها تبلورت المبادرات لاحقا لتنتظم
تحت مظلات اوسع وفي الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر 2014 اعلن عن توحدها تحت اسم الخوذ
البيضاء لتكون بمثابه الدفاع المدني في
المناطق الخارجه عن سيطره النظام خلال
السنوات اللاحقه لذلك تقول المنظمه انها
نجحت في انقاذ حياه نحو 125 الف انسان من
تحت انقاض القصف والركام فقدت خلالها نحو
ثلاثمائه من افرادها خلال عملهم نصفهم في
ضربات استهد عمدا من قبل قوات النظام
وحلفائه كما يقول الموقع الرسمي للمنظمه
اعتمدت الخوذ البيضاء وما زالت على
المتطوعين والمتطوعات من مختلف المدن
السوريه ومن كافه فئات المجتمع ويعمل فيها
اليوم نحو ثلاثه الاف متطوع منذ فجر
السادس من فبراير الماضي وجدت منظمه الخوذ
البيضاء نفسها امام كارثه غير مسبوقه اذ
كانت الخيار الاول والاخير للملايين من
السوريين القاطنين في شمال البلاد
لانقاذهم من تداعيات زلزال هو الاعنف في
المنطقه منذ نحو قرن تقول المنظمه انها
سابقت الزمن لانقاذ العالقين تحت انقاض
المباني والمنازل المنهاره والاغاثه عشرات
الالاف من المنكوبين ممن شردهم الزلزال
رغم امكانياتها المحدوده والمتواضعه
وافتقارها الى المعدات والالات الثقيله